- [Presenter] In this
video, we're gonna talk
about how energy is stored in field
and in particular, how if we
change the position of things
within that field, how it
might change the energy.
So, just as a bit of a refresher,
let's remind ourselves what energy is.
It is the capacity to do work.
And we've also seen that work,
we can view it as equal
to the magnitude of force
times the displacement in
the direction of that force.
And then we can also remind
ourselves what a field is.
And I'm not just talking about a big lawn
or something like that, a football field.
I'm talking about a general
idea in physics that's used.
It's really just a concept
that allows us to predict
and explain how to things that
are not touching each other
are still interacting,
are still able to exert
forces on each other.
And in other videos, I've
also talked about that.
Really nothing in this
universe is touching.
We just conceptualize
that sometimes they are.
But just as an example of a field,
we have an electric field here.
I could have done another type of field,
we could have done a magnetic field,
we could have done a gravitational field.
Although when you study general relativity
which Einstein gave us,
we realize that it might
not exactly be optimal
to think about it as a field.
But in an electric field, right over here,
we have a positive charge,
we have a negative charge.
We know from experience
that these two things attract each other
and the convention is to
draw these field lines
that go from the positive
towards the negative.
Now, if we were to just let
go of these two point charges
over here, what would happen?
Well, we know that due to the
electric field constructed
or created or that we imagined was created
by this negative point charge,
this positive charge would have a force
acting on it towards the negative charge
and vice versa due to the electric field
that is created by the positive charge.
The negative charge is
going to also be attracted
to the positive charge.
They're both going to
move towards each other.
And so, when we talk
about energy in fields
or energy stored in fields,
in our initial configuration,
how is there energy in this field?
How is their capacity to do work?
Pause this video and think about that.
Well, think about it this way.
Imagine if each of these
charges were attached
to some type of a mass,
let me do this in a color
you can actually see.
So, let's say that this is
towing some type of a mass
and this is towing some type
of a mass right over here.
Well, when you let go and
the forces are exerted
on each of these point charges,
assuming that the forces are large enough,
they're going to be able
to pull these masses
towards each other.
So, there's a potential amount
of work that could be done
and it would essentially keep happening
until these point charges touch.
And I used air quotes with my hand
even though you can't see it,
or until they can't get
any closer to each other
or some other is keeping
them from getting any closer
to each other.
So now, let me think about how
could I increase the energy
that is stored in this field.
Pause the video and think about that.
Well, what if I were to
keep the positive charge
where it is, but if I were
to take the negative charge
and if I were to move it
in a direction opposite
from the force direction that
the field is trying to exert.
So, instead of the negative charge there,
what if I moved it all the way out there?
Once again, let me do that in
a color you can actually see.
Well, if I moved it out here
and we're still towing
some type of a mass,
you can see that when I moved
it against the direction
that the force of the
field is trying to exert,
that I've increased
the energy in the field
because now I can do more work.
I can drag this potential
mass over a larger distance.
So, we have a general principle here.
If we let these charges go in
the direction of the forces
that are being exerted
on them due to the field,
we're going to reduce
the energy in the field.
But then if we are able to
move them against the forces
of the field, and as you can imagine,
we're going to have to put energy
into the system to do that.
But if we do that, then
we're storing more energy
in this field because in that case,
they're going to be further
away from each other
and so they could drag their little masses
that they're towing even further.